you can
right
all right everybody I'd like to get
started so welcome to this afternoon's
session the first half of this session
will be of ameica use thank you well
thanks for inviting me
so um if I start to talk up talk about
this work I have with Rahul Jane Rahul
Jain and Thomas Watson
it's appeared in folks one year ago and
we basically have just mine one main
result so it's just good to come out and
say what it is so we construct a family
of graphs that have nearly maximal
extension complexity for their
independent set pollito so main theorem
just to spell it out there exist n node
graphs
that's that the independent set polytope
I used this notation I guess some people
call this table set polytopes they have
nearly maximal complexity maximum
complexity would be exponential in n but
we come only almost there so it's a
exponential in n over log n so if you
think back to the first lower bounds we
had for extended formulations in this
work of hearing in others like optimal
lower bounds for correlation and TSB and
we had lower bounds for matching from
those results you can get by reduction
some lower bounds on independence at
polytopes
and they would be exponential in root n
and in fact prior to this result there
wasn't explicit 0 and polytopes
so that's convex hulls of 0 1 sets with
extension convexity larger than root of
the ambient dimension so this is the
first that kind of breaks this routine
frontier and yeah it's almost maximal so
you
we know from Rothfuss is counting
argument that well there are doubly
experiment many 0 1 polytope so most of
them require district description length
exponential in n and by a like a refined
coding language you can conclude that
most of them have exponential in
extinction complexity well we don't
quite match that so it's a kind of an
artifact or a proof that we do need this
law getting the exponent it's annoying
you'd like of course an optimal result
but more so here because independent set
polytopes are often starting points for
reductions so if you're up to here you'd
be optimal for many other problems also
if without log n you could say that you
proved the exponential time hypothesis
for extension complexity but we're not
quite there and I think Sebastian tells
me that if ii-if whether you did have
the log and then you would start
developing ahead of a PCP theory inside
extension complexity
one more motivation to get rid of that
so that's the main result and since this
is ancient work one year ago already so
I thought how can I make this exciting
for me as a presenter so I thought I'll
actually also present a kind of a bonus
result which we realized holds after we
got this and that's in the regime where
we put some bound on the independence
number of the graph I should maybe thank
this guy awesome Buchan and asked us
whether our methods give anything in
this regime so here's the bonus results
that's again consider n note graphs and
you put some bound on the independence
number so you should think of this as
kind of the fixed parameter tractability
setting where these are the size of the
independent set is the parameter so
let's say the independence number of our
graph is some K which you should think
of as a large constant or formally this
result holds up to K being some small
polynomial then what's the extension
capacity of innocent polytopes for these
kinds of graphs
well there are at most n choose K
possible independent sets so the trivial
upper bound is the trivial upper bound
is n to the K and that's what we can
match exactly
equals and to order King so yeah it's a
kind of a fixed parameter tractability
setting and it's known by reductions
that if you have bounce like this you
can get something in this regime even
the Turing machine setting there are
reductions that say if you assume that
the exponential time hypothesis holds
notes at request you to the n complexity
by reductions you could get something in
the fixed parameter setting and those
reductions work even in the extension
complexity setting in particular if you
applied such reductions to this result
you would get a lower bound here that's
n to the power K over log K because
because of this annoying thing so this
result then is kind of incomparable to
this but the reason why you would get
something optimal at least so I think
today all that so both are proved by a
similar high-level approach but it turns
out this is a lot easier because we can
at a crucial practical point rely on a
what I call the security communication
lifting theorems so mainly maybe sketch
the proof of this guy and then tell you
where BAM the two priests diverge and
it's going to be a very chillaxed
lecture it's mostly about reductions I'm
not going to delve too much into
technicalities here but I think
reductions are important here because
ironically enough graphs are so
expressive that it's not even clear
where you would start to look for the
hardness of an independent set polytopes
there are too many possibilities it's a
problem of too many choices so the
reductions they identify a hard core
like some plausible hard setting for an
independent set polytope and it kind of
conceptually solves the problem so then
you can maybe five i've shown you the
reductions you can kind of sit down and
start using all the available technical
tools like information complex ten what
half we have to actually prove like
numerically some lower bounds but mostly
about reductions today
okay so this is maybe the seems to have
a moment and okay so since I have you
here I also want to advertise another
set of results about independence at
polytopes we have in some related papers
and those have to do with an interesting
sub matrix of the independent set
polytope so it's already on ACOG is
defined this thing called clique versus
independent set so these are the slack
matrix you get out of thumb so what
clicky inequalities so let me just spell
this out it's called the Clippers
independent set and I'm really defining
a sub matrix of the slack matrix of any
dependence at polytope but I'm using
communication language because that's
what I like the most you gets more
active language more algorithmic maybe
so I say Alice which really holds a
vertex of an independent set polytope so
Alice receives an independent setting in
the graph so again we have some in node
graph
nice housing independent set and forb
this is the the object that you will
define an interesting linear inequality
for the polytope also King
and the interesting inequality is just
that any independent set can only
contain at most one note from the clique
so you can write this out as a linear
inequality like the the sum of the nodes
of Y those coordinate analysis indicate
a vector should be at least at most one
so another way to say it is at the
intersection of these two sets if you
use the set notation is that most one ok
the corresponding slack is just then
it's just you have to be careful here to
get get it right so it's 1 minus
quantity non negative thing 0 or 1 so
one reason this slack matrices are
interesting is that it captures well the
non negative rank of the slack matrix
captures the extension complexity of of
in the pedicel persepolis when G is
perfect and Jana cork is already his
paper showed that this matrix has
relatively small non-negative rank so
for every G not only perfect but I which
we graph the non negative ranked most
quasi-polynomial so particular for
perfect graphs that's a bound on the
extension complexity and the major
question is is this the best or can you
have safer perfect graphs polynomial
excitation complexity
well this remains open but what we have
proved in some related work is some
lower bounds on the non negative rank
for general growths so one thing we can
show is that there are graphs again not
perfect
where well not only little negative rank
but even the kaabah number which is asks
how many rectangles do you need to cover
all the non negative entries it's a
lower bound and non-negative rank
carbon number can be super polynomial so
into the log something like point one so
this is
a few years ago and I should mention
just this year at IDC s this was
improved a little bit by uh david Hitomi
and tall
I guess the conjecture is that this
really should be matched the upper bound
that's my conjecture it's clearly
converging towards it already but so
that's a copy number we can achieve
nearly the optimum if you not only look
at the cover number but the whole like
the original question the non- ranked
again laughs we're gonna get to your
bank at least in two and okay there are
some lost and blah blah gloss in the
exponent and this result it's hidden in
a paper or half with Jai Ram Tony and
Tom and okay I hesitate like 15 or 70 we
get had like two years to get this
published but it did appear in I called
this year and the way the main results
of this paper are expressed is studying
the the randomized communication
complexity of this you know understood
as a decision problem but in fact the
previous strong enough that it proved a
lower bound even for the non- ranked in
fact slightly stronger it's even for the
approximate non-negative rank which
means there's not only the non negative
ranked low but even if I'm allowed to
perturb the entries here by one percent
point twice the non negative rank is
still high so approximate non negative
rank lower bounds randomized
communication complexity actually that's
a method we use them
so I think these all the results I
wanted to advertise and for the rest of
the talk will be just going into seeing
how how this is pretty
I did mention these results are also
obtained using similar tools but very
different reductions so it's all about
this interplay between man query and
communication complexity as you'll see
any questions about the results excuse
my flu
I want through medication but it's is
fine
with the audience is a little wobbly
today but but who manage so this
identified an interesting sub matrix and
I maybe want to approach this result
similarly identify an interesting sub
matrix of the flacc matrix and kind of
half tongue-in-cheek in analogy with
kick for the nobility sub game like over
following an independent set versus
independent set game so this is the
source of hardness for this result
so this is a game again we have a graph
now let's say that the vertices are
partitioned into left and right pieces
the graph is not bipartite it's just
that we've split the nodes and I'll
assume that the independence number of
this graph is bounded this K is the same
KS there so I can now define an
interesting well it's going to be a
search problem for starters so here this
is an independent set from the left hand
side of the graph and the set of size k
and Bobby's very similar why from the
right side of the graph so so Alice and
Bob have K sites independent sets on
left and right and I've kind of
syntactically made them disjoint so the
union of these two guys is a set of size
2k but I'm assuming the independence
number is smaller so it means that there
must be an edge between Alice and Bob
sets and an associated such problem is
to find such an edge find an edge that
crosses the two sets except I'm going to
write it down a little bit awkwardly I'm
saying find an Alice side of the node of
such an edge so find a node V in Alice's
set that's adjacent to something in Bob
set so n is here all the neighbors of Y
let's set this up in such a way that
this set is always non empty and I think
in my abstract I talked about a
connection between extension complexity
and circuit complexity or monotone
circuit complexity
I bought maybe use that language here
except to say that monotone circuit
complexity or monotone circuit depth can
be characterized in a communication
language it's all about search problems
in communication complexity and this is
a search problem so the connection which
is crucial to these results is that from
any search problem there's a very nice
Associated slack matrix or at least a
non-negative function defined on this
domain that simply expresses the fact
that our search probably is total so for
any X and one
this set is non empty so I'm going to
use a red arrow so this is a connection
that was introduced by rubbish as some
extension of something or a spur of did
is well we're doing it for a single
search problem but you could do this for
anything but whenever you have a total
search problem it's a very kind of a non
trivial fact about it is that is this is
its totality it's the fact that I call
this now the slack is that they said
it's empty so it's non empty this is a
slice at least one or in really slack
form the number of witnesses or
solutions to the search problem - one is
a non-negative quantity so this is this
will be our slack but we need to be
careful it's picked from the slack
matrix of the independent set pull it up
off the left side of the graph so this
is in G induced on the left nodes
so again X is now an independent set in
in the left solid and I've identified
here a bunch of interesting subset of
the left-hand side that must intersect
every K independent set there so I can
write this linear inequality that says
this there's an intersection just this
linear form is at least one
okay there's more I mean this this
definition was of course inspired by
this but there's more so it turns out
this search problem is at least as hard
as this so here I may be asking for the
deterministic communication complexity
of solving the search problem here I'm
asking what's the non-negative rank of
this slack matrix and I claim that if
you have an efficient deterministic
protocol you immediately get an
efficient non negative rack
decomposition and again this is this
argument by true bash and I'll explain
it in words it not won't be terribly
important but the how they go from a
deterministic protocol here to a non
negative article position firstly let me
use this language I really like of
characterizing non negative rank are
really the log of the non negative rank
I guess in terms of a communication
complexity language I think this was
discussed earlier on so the log of the
non negative rank of a non negative
matrix it's the least cost of a
randomized protocol that computes this
matrix in expectation this people heard
about this characterization I maybe like
to say more in a self-documenting manner
that what we are supposed to do here to
give a non negative rank decomposition
is to design a randomized protocol whose
accept as probability so the protocol
always accepts or rejects but the
probability with which which it accepts
is proportional to these non-negative
numbers so now the numbers are integers
but if you scale them down small enough
so that you can interpret them as
probabilities then they are indeed
accepted probabilities of some efficient
randomized protocol so really I'm
claiming deterministic solution here
implies a randomized protocol whose
acceptance probably is proportional to
this number and the argument is really
simple two steps I assume I have a
protocol here so what can we do we run
it we find a weakness in one of these
guys in this set
so we have this in our hand and the
second step of the protocol we have to
use in introduce randomness what we do
is we sample a uniform random node from
Alice's site distinct from the one we
found and then we check is this node we
sampled is that another solution to the
search problem
so really it's this thing that we found
in the first step that's the -1 the
second stage of the algorithm is just
going to accept with probability
proportional to how many other witnesses
are there for this search problem so
it's a nice connection but somehow it
goes in the wrong direction for us
because we really wanted to prove lower
bound we want to show this has large
your negative rank but the connection
doesn't give us anything it goes the
wrong direction we'd maybe like to say
that if the search problem was hard then
automatically this is hard but that's
the wrong direction it in general you
can't hope for this converse to hold
there are examples for for other search
problems but it does say that actually
it was known in previous worker search
problem of this kind of hard not only
for deterministic protocols were even
for randomized the this connection says
we need to strengthen existing results
that this is kind of already a hard core
that if this is what you might hope that
you get lucky that the associated slack
major is also hard okay so this sort of
she'll still solve the conceptual puzzle
of you know what's the graph going to be
I haven't really constructed a graph and
so that's what we're going to do next
the inspiration for constructing a graph
is now from the simpler model of query
complexity not Alice and Bob
communicating but a simpler model where
it's easier to prove analogous results
lower bands are easier to prove so I was
a bit unsure how this audience whether
you know about query complexity so this
study of decision trees that get as
input one string of bits and there are
two query individual bits so you could
view what I now say in in that context
so I'm going to introduce it's a very
well-known hard search problem in the
context of query complexity and will end
up in the end somehow reducing it to
that end and carrying the hardest with
us this is a search problem that's this
is inspired by one of the most widely
studied see if CNF contradictions
improve complexity so we call it the
titan search problem
firstly traditionally these fighting
contradictions they're just
unsatisfiable csps with xor constraints
it's just some name that proof
complexity people like to attach to this
so you can define them relative to any
graph but let me pick a hard graph so
take a three regular expander on some
some set of nodes and edges and now the
parameters are such that the I have K
edges it is regular I will have order of
K nodes as a sparse graph and I define
an unsatisfiable X or CSB by
interpreting each node of the graph as a
parity constraint on its incident edges
so I have maybe three incoming edges red
ones at two and this is representing a
parity constraint maybe I'm saying
these guys should shop some to one
so as long as I take my graph to have an
odd number of edges this will be
unsatisfiable quite easy to see I have
odd many such constraints with okay
left-hand sides with the right-hand side
anyway so I if I were to sum together or
many of these constraints I would get
one on the left hand side it because
it's sum of odd many ones on the right
hand side eats variable participates in
two constraints so there would be up
here twice in the sum so they would
cancel themselves out so you get 1
equals 0
so it's unsatisfiable well there's a
general principle whenever you have an
unsatisfiable CNF CNF rcsb formula you
can define an Associated search problem
where the input
it's a truth assignment to the
underlying variables so here they're the
edges so evil is a truth assignment and
okay the CSP is unsatisfiable meaning
that on any assignment there are some
parity constraints that are violated
that are unsatisfied and so such problem
is just to find one of them so find a
node that is violated and so this is a
set of nodes and violated under this
assignment okay so these are classically
really hard for decision trees and you
can do the same trick as we did there
it's a search problem we can be inspired
and define a non negative function on
our input space that expresses the fact
that the functions total that this set
is non empty so again a similar red
arrow and we can define a non negative
function I shouldn't call it slack I
call it slack in quotation marks because
there's no polytope yet but this is a
non negative function
so it's just kind of matching what we're
doing here
and since this is intuitively hard I
mean people have proved it in complexity
that determines decision trees can't
really find these violations fast and in
our paper I guess for the first time we
also proved that even randomized
decisions decision trees can't find this
fast well it's reasonable to suppose
that somehow the game where you need to
design a randomized decision tree whose
acceptance probability is proportional
to this quantity should also be hard and
so that's what we wish oh I should maybe
spell out what the query complex the
analog of non-negative rank is I mean I
just kind of implicitly defined it like
the model is randomized decision trees
whose acceptors probably you care about
but not another way to measure the
complexity or define the same notion is
to look at it's what we call Conoco into
degree so in suggestive notation it's
it's like to call this function non
negative function f
so what is this it's only cold agree
something that is related to share
Hallie Adams hierarchies so I need to
define what a conical glutton is well
it's a non- analog of polynomials so it
looks something like this
you are taking us so this is a
representation for a non-negative
boolean function which is a conical
combination so you have some
coefficients that are non-negative of
hunters or it suffices to say
conjunctions of input literals CI so
this is a conjunction the good little so
for example Z 1 Z 2 negated so these are
syntactic non-negative components out of
which you want to construct your
non-negative function so the degree of
such an expression is the maximum width
of a conjunction you're using in it and
if I give you a non negative function
you can ask what's the least degree of a
chronical hunter that exactly
represented so this is kind of a query
convex the analog with no negative rank
and it's for this this guy that we show
hardness
so we can show and this is not terribly
hard I don't have time to maybe go into
it the truth is like two pages which
should be considered relatively simple
in this case is that for this function
it has full Monica hunter degree so
somehow this is the source of hardness
in at least here we've proof some
results that seem analogous to what we
really want but we need to go there
through reductions
I didn't say only reductions this a
major step where you amplify hardness in
in a very weak model of computation to
something in a more powerful model of
computation and that's the next step so
what remains is to do this go over there
and it's done in two steps and so I have
two boards in between coincidence or
intelligent design
so the connection between the extension
complexity and the slack matrix the
standard connection between just erased
the end of the data being implied by the
non- n matrix is that so you're talking
about this result yeah so if I can show
that the non negative rank of you know
this guy is n to the order K then that's
equal to the main result or like this is
a particular sub matrix that I identify
this hard the pre from here to the
actual main result the bonus result
should be complete okay so the first
step is to just somehow come up with a
some communication analog of this
problem that's equally hard and so
that's exactly what these queries of
communication lifting theorems allow you
to do when Raghu is going to talk about
this by the way in the next talk so I'm
just going to quickly formulate what it
what it says so here the input is K bits
there's no Alice and Bob but the
standard way to convert it into a
two-party communication problem is to
take your problem let's call it some
name like cycling problems as problem
McGruff T
so it has these K input bits
and the way we can to convert this into
a communication problem is we're just
going to plug into the inputs a small
two-party function so we call it G so G
or the gadget
so it takes some inputs from Alice and
lets it it takes log M bits from Alice
log M bits from Bob it spits out one bit
this will be log n bits
listen and I have K of these all
together
so it is a communication problem Alice
gets all the first inputs Bacchus all
the second input and they're supposed to
solve this search problem on input which
is the output of the gadgets now the
intuition is that if you choose this
gadget carefully enough so that it's
complicated for protocols to compute
that they need to spend some bits of
communication to even figure out what
the output of a particular gadget is
then the composed problem that the
lifted problem intuitively it's hard I
mean you don't even know what the inputs
to the outer object here are before you
communicate enough information about the
inputs so it's literally as if she
wanted to query a particular input you
need to spend communication so that's
exactly what a lifting theorem
formalizes now the choice of the gadget
is left to the lifting theorem you want
to choose it to be small
presumably what complexity of this guy
to be dominated by the query complexity
of the outer object and so far these
little curves are known and we're going
to use them when G is the inner product
gadget what really matter for our
reductions what it is but here's one
choice under which this works
concreteness so G on input 2 log n bit
strings it's just the inner product
I mean I'm interpreting those binary
strings it's just this mod - yeah it's
like economically a hard communication
problem it just melts to make the
following theorem true so this is the
lifting theorem this is joint with a
hollow vet raw Mecca thomas watson and
david zuckerman a few years ago Bragg
was going to talk about a subsequent
work to this which is a bit more
sophisticated but for this we only need
the old version of the result so it says
that under this choice of a gadget you
can lift cornica 1/2 degree into non-
rank so I would really be applying it
for the associated number of witnesses
gay - one game so it is it would really
be F like it says it for all
more negative functions you can
characterize the non- rank of this
lifted problems I I can identify this
with a matrix where Alice is input index
the rows Bob's input indexes two columns
so it's some non-negative matrix so I
guess the formalism is f composed with K
copies of the gadget so if the log of
the non-negative rank should be the
chronical 1/2 degree of F times maybe
the complexity of the gadget which well
intuitively should be log M like you
should say log M bits of communication
to to compute a single copy of the
gadget so this is saying that to kind of
compute this you need these many copies
of the gadgets to be computed
and okay this would be the ideal theorem
but well our tools are a little bit
blunt and you can only prove such a
thing assuming that not just that the
colleague over the degree is large but a
more robust assumption that it's
approximate conical hunter degrees large
meaning that even to express any
function close to F in like L infinity
distance like point wise 1%
approximation should also be hard so
that's the approximate version of this
the least degree of a conic over the
that agrees with F point wise so that we
can lift into this communication domain
and you even get some lower bound on the
approximate non-negative rank out of
this so that's just an application of
this this type of theorem but okay what
we get is some kind of a compose problem
that doesn't necessarily look like this
yet so the final step is to massage this
into a problem of that form
the relations with your monkey so good
point good point
so to apply this theorem you need the
gadget to be large enough so important
that M here is something like some
polynomial in K I should mention this is
the point where the proofs diverge for
the two theorems the bonus result
follows from this because I can use a
large gadget if I had a such a theorem
for a constant size gadget um being a
constant not depending on K I would get
the main result not even without the log
factor the factor loss in the exponent
but maximal due to the N lower bound but
we don't know how to do this for courses
or schedules so the main result instead
of applying such a thing we just replace
an application of this with an ad-hoc
argument you compose your Titan problem
with a constant size thing and then you
just directly analyze it because we
can't rely on a general theorem yeah
that's a good point but yeah for the
fixed parameter setting large or not
even terribly large it's like the gadget
sighting in bits is just logarithmic in
K so um so it's it's enough for the
bonus result
okay so the last bit isn't terribly
exciting it's it's a reduction that's
many versions of it have been used in
the literature in fact this reduction is
going to look very much like these
reductions that say from let's say
assuming ETH you can get these results
for a clique and so forth I think all
these things go back to something like
sub reductions of 5k in the 90s so it's
some kind of a np-completeness reduction
[Applause]
so I'm always going to give these
reductions for the underlying search
problem with the understanding that you
can always do this red arrow thing of
getting this non-negative function out
of it this composed search problem so
this is also a search problem associated
with an unsatisfiable Ciena a CSP it's
just the constraints has now been
composed themselves with the gadget so a
single constraint in this compost
problem is of this form so I had a
parity constraint
now here each of these variables is an
output of a gadget
okay so they take some input from Alice
I'll just gathered them on the left-hand
side so some symbol X 1 X 2 X 3 they pop
input
if y1 up to Y 3
so it's like now we have a new CSP which
is kind of compared east so the new
constraints look like this I have K of
them that was the number of edges I
chose for my graph and now I just kind
of need to encode K constraints yes that
they kind of look like this independent
set versus independent set and I'll just
tell you how to map a single constraint
inside this graph so the graph is again
in two parts left and right and for a
single constraint I'm going to insert a
clique in the graph for Alice and clique
in the graph for Bob and these links
they are of size M cubed so think of all
the nodes as being in want one
correspondence with all possible inputs
that a lead might have to that
constraint and similarly here
so since these are clicks it just means
that in any independent set of Alice and
Bob you only can pick only one note from
this click so this and nodes are in
one-to-one correspondence with these
inputs of the gadget the national thing
is to define a graph between the two
clicks in a way that depends on whether
the node left and right together satisfy
the the new constraint so okay let's say
that this node corresponds to some node
here and this correspond to something
over here and you'd put here an edge
something like you put no edge if the
corresponding inputs do satisfy the
constraint so it's for this
a constraint see so no edge if C is
satisfied
so you're essentially encoding the truth
table of this gadget as a graph between
the two clicks so that's how you handle
a single constraint but you had K of
them so you just add K pairs there are
more pairs of clicks okay so all
together gave them and you have some
graphs here including the constraints
and you're also going to add some inter
clique edges both on left and right so
you want to enforce that a maximal
independent set on the left who are
correspond in one-to-one fashion to some
global assignment the K symbols so you
want maximal maximal independent sets on
the left is one-to-one correspondence
with some
so you introduce some edges that enforce
the fact that the the partial assignment
setting three symbols to some
coordinates another three symbols here
they need to be consistent they can't
assign same coordinate different symbols
and you're just going to enforce it by
adding an edge between every two
inconsistent assignments so that's the
whole construction the point is that
given an input to this compost problem K
symbols from this set of numbers one
word M there you want one corresponds to
B the maximal independent set and since
we know that the underlying this
lighting problem was unsatisfiable means
that no matter which K independent set I
pick here and here there will be some
constraint that's unsatisfied meaning
the corresponding nodes are going to
have an edge between them so that's
that's basically the ratio reductions of
these reductions they map weaknesses
into witnesses in a one-to-one manner so
they complexity people would call them
parsimonious and that's the reason why
even though I just gave the reductions
for the search problems you can always
go to this non negative no negative
slack function and they correspond to
each other because of this parsimonious
miss okay so I think that's pretty much
the whole reduction so any any questions
about this
just be the GNSS reduction but you
enforce this gadget on top of it yeah
it's basically that but adapted to a
two-party setting so many variations so
you can do the displace is essentially
the same yeah I guess the point was here
that well you really start from you know
something that is so simple to analyze
that people have done this improve
complexity a lot and then by reductions
eventually going to embed it into any
dependency to pull it on and again it
didn't really even matter that it's an
independent set pull it up early and if
you had stopped here it would already
been kind of interesting because you
know that you can extract by this red
arrow trick some interesting
inequalities for some zero and polytope
but maybe you didn't wouldn't have seen
that it really is an independence at
polytope okay so then I think I have
five minutes left I'm just going to
mention one open problem as I'm really
annoyed by and that's to prove lower
bound for independence at polytopes of
mate roads a lot of growths of mate
roads
okay
so what's known I mean firstly why would
you want to prove that some major
independent said pull it up so hard so
convex hulls of independent sets of
matrix well it would be the magista kind
of a marketing speech I feel like it's a
natural enough problem in itself but
here's what you could say it's trivial
to optimize linear functions of a matrix
like greedy algorithm does it so it
would be the ultimate insult to linear
programming if you couldn't even do this
however this technicality here which is
that there are very many matrix doubly
exponentially many and again by a
counting argument you can show that most
majors are hard but the reason is but
they just require so large and
description so we really want an
explicit mate roit to make sense of this
and the problem is that for natural
families of matrix you could think of
there's a line of work that shows that
well they're actually all easy you can
find polynomial size extended
formulations for them so there are kind
of in an annoying place where well I
have all this machinery I've been
developing in my PhD thesis and I can't
start applying them because we don't
have a candidate for a heart Metroid and
I want to leave you with kind of a nice
observation about a yet another barrier
to proving lower bounds for these matric
polytopes which i found a bit surprising
so that is that if you look at the the
counting argument now why are there so
many mate roads well it's because there
are so many paving Metroid's and they
look like this so yes your lattice of
all subsets of a universe of size in
everything here are the empty set here
and
a paving maitre d's basically it looks
like this this some level K South so
that everything above level K is
dependent everything below K is
independent but within level K you have
both independent dependent sets you can
construct such matrix out of error
correcting codes for example and and by
that you can see that there are doubly
exponentially many of them so accounting
argument already works for this family
of matrix so you'd think that okay if
these natural families that people have
studied they don't yield hard candidates
well here's a family that's certain to
have large hard Metroid's but there's a
formal barrier to exhibiting any
explicit such may trade and that goes
back to this connection I didn't really
go into how search problems are
connected to monotone circuit complexity
so I'm going to make this claim that if
you can exhibit any paving Metroid and
improve a non-negative rank lower bound
for it slack matrix it implies genuine
circuit lower bounds like circuit depth
lower bounds not it not in the monotone
setting but in the fully general non
monotone setting so this should be quite
quite surprising because we've we think
okay we can prove non-negative right
robots which are staged and and there
are a lot of methods for them there
shouldn't be any a prior or right
barriers but in this setting it turns
out that if you just string together a
couple of observations that are known
about circuit complexity you can
identify this place where we have many
hard pullers but you can't hope to prove
it otherwise you separate complexity
classics like NC from NP or something
and and we nurturing a would so I found
this surprising if you're interested I
I've written this observation in the
open problem section of my PhD thesis
but it's just one facet of why this
problem is so interesting and you would
existing techniques don't seem to work
okay so I think old and there
Thanks so do you expect that there's a
lifting theorem for a constant so that's
that's what i conjecture we don't have
any counter examples and i
optimistically like to believe you that
they do hold but yeah so there are
plenty of motivation to do this like
this is one of the most crucial ones
other motivations is for monotone
circuits sighs you could maybe beat the
existing quantitatively the existing
records which are exponential in cube
root of the input length but now with
this kind of a machinery you would hope
to get to to the end and you would
basically redo all of communication
complexity you could prove lower bounds
optimal lower bunch like set
disjointness and gap hamming and all
these basic functions if you just had
these lifting theater for a constant
size gadget plenty of motivation but
it's a hard problem the independence
politics that you construct what do we
know about this might need the extension
complexity these family of graphs and I
would there are kind of off lifted forms
I would imagine that the I'm the only
SDP lower bounds we have that machinery
also gives something quantitatively I'm
not quite sure what you get but
and other questions
all right then we continue
[Applause]